welcome back everybody we have a new
plot leak for you today let me tell you
that this one is probably the best one
that i've seen so far and i tell you
that because it includes the cameos as
well as the variants and so far in the
last two that i've done videos on we do
not have the inclusion of cameos nor the
variants of doctor strange and this one
finally does
so sit back and enjoy the movie begins
with juana maximoff at her cabin in the
woods more to attacks her for the events
of west view but wanda defeats him mordo
claims that he will never stop coming
after wanda she says she knows and
decapitates him strange takes america to
the sanctum to search for a book of
spells when gargantuas breaks through
and kills him america teleports away
with defender strange's body as the
universe collapses and ends up in the
mcu where the prime strange is attending
the wedding of his ex-girlfriend
christine palmer gargantos attacks
looking for america and strange fights
him wong arrives to help and distracts
gargantos long enough for strange to
impale him through the eye america leads
strange and wong to defender strange's
dead body and explains that she can
create portals between universes wong
deduces that someone summoned gargantos
and takes america to comartage for
protection where they meet guardian
minotaur rentra meanwhile strange visits
wanda in her cabin to ask for help she
is evasive and he feels the dark
presence of the darkhold and realizes
wanda summoned garganto wanda fights
strange and explains that her children
tommy and billy are lost in the
multiverse and she needs the dark hole
to find them juan is only able to
possess the bodies of her variants and
needs america to physically traverse the
multiverse strange argues that the
darkholds is warping wanda's mind but
she refuses to listen and strange is
forced to teleport back to camartage
strange warns wong about wanda wong
tells strange about the prophecy that
the scarlet witch will destroy reality
wong claims that if wanda is the scarlet
witch she must be killed but strange
refuses to accept this and is convinced
that he can kill wanda one attacks the
comartaj strange protects america while
wang and the sorcerers fight wanda
america can't control her powers and
accidentally teleports herself and
strange to a universe where mordo is the
sorcerer's supreme they ask for help but
he abducts them instead mordo brings a
strange and america before the
illuminati a secret society that is
assembled to protect the multiverse
illuminati are professor charles xavier
reed richards peggy carter maria rambo
balder and mordo mortal believes strange
and america should be killed for
endangering reality but xavier imprisons
them instead under the supervision of a
variant of palmer meanwhile juana
possesses the body of her variant of the
illuminati's universe and attacks their
lair killing balder and injuring carter
rambo and richards xavier battles wanda
and nearly exercises her but she
overpowers him and kills him her dark
presence causes her variance bodies to
rapidly deteriorate strange escapes and
is attacked by mortal while searching
for america but she manages to defeat
him palmer rescues strange in america
and uses a bracelet to teleport them to
another universe and retrieve a spell
capable of curing wanda wanda intercepts
them kanap's america and abandoned
strange and palmer in a dying universe
unaware that strange has the spell
meanwhile the sorcerers retrieve the
darkhold and create a protected barrier
around it to keep wanda away wanda
breaks through by inflicting nightmarish
visions into the minds of the novice
sorcerer and abducts wong so she can
lead her to the birthplace of chaos
magic in one gore mountain in wondergore
wanda harnesses america's powers and
opens a portal to the universe where
billy and tommy are wong realizes that
wanda is being manipulated by demons to
weaken the cosmic barriers and plunge
the multiverse into chaos meanwhile
strange fights strange supreme who was
also corrupted by chaos magic for
possession of the spell and defeats him
strange possesses the dead body of
defender strain turning it into a zombie
and manages to teleport into one decor
and talk to america encouraging her to
embrace her power america manages to
open a portal to bring strange m palmer
into wondergore while rintra and the
surviving sorcerers arrive to rescue
wang to want a surprise a billy and
tommy are living with a loving adoptive
family in a farm not in danger as a
darkhold had influenced her into
believing strange confronts her with the
spells but the demons compel wanda to
attack him and they battle across the
multiverse strange brings wanda back to
wondergore where he manages to cast the
spell and free her from the influence of
chaos magic with the help of his allies
the demons begin spreading through the
universes one of regains control and
sacrifices herself to destroy wonder
gore mountain and save the multiverse
strange apologizes to huang and bows to
him accepting wang as the sorcerer's
supreme palmer returns to her universe
to reform the illuminati strange takes
america as his apprentice having
developed a fatherly bond with her in a
post-credits scene strange realizes that
he is infected by chaos magic as well
that's it guys thank you so much for
those of you who stuck around this one
is definitely uh probably the best one
i've seen so far uh there is no mention
of clea as we've seen in other ones
there is also the huge plot point where
wanda apparently sacrifices herself i
don't see that happening at least for
the sake of the mcu because she
apparently uh has signed for seven more
years and killing ron from this movie
makes no sense so i personally want to
say that that part is definitely either
before reshoots or simply incorrect uh
no mention of doctor strange growing a
third eye either which i've seen pretty
much through all the leaks that i've
read and that supposedly does happen at
the end of the movie uh not sure if
that's relevant but it's definitely
something to judge these plot leaks by
anyways do me a favor if you haven't
already please subscribe turn on
notifications i am doing this every day
i'll see you guys tomorrow thanks guys